después de la reciente aprobación de la
agencia europea de medicamentos ahora
son 615 las dosis de la vacuna de facer
contra el cob y 19 que se están
extrayendo de cada vial pero a las
enfermeras de este centro de vacunación
les ha resultado complicado exprimir la
sexta dosis
si la persona que prepara la vacuna está
distraída o estresada tal vez podría
cometer un error y eso podría afectar a
la cantidad de dosis que sacamos del
vial y godoy el gmail hecho botox y
meses porque seis dosis significa que
estamos usando toda la vacuna en el
vídeo son 100 mililitros hate extraer
una sexta dosis ha permitido a fayza
reducir de 120 millones a 100 millones
el número de viales entregadas a la
unión europea sin dejar de cumplir su
compromiso de 600 millones de dosis en
un comunicado pzifer dijo que está
respetando su calendario de entregas y
que el cambio no tendrá ningún impacto
en el desarrollo de la vacunación pero
podría ser una fuente de ingresos para
el gigante farmacéutico
a unos 12 euros por dosis la reventa de
los 20 millones de viales adicionales
podrían generarle a la empresa 1500
millones de euros extra
si el contrato se vendió por dosis y no
por frascos entonces no hay nada que
digas de facer no ha respetado su
obligación contacto
faisal podría enfrentarse a la presión
de italia miembro de la unión europea
que ha prometido demandar al fabricante
de medicamentos además de los problemas
registrados con pzifer astrazéneca
anunció a la unión europea un recorte de
hasta el 60 por ciento en la entrega de
sus vacunas durante el primer trimestre
los retrasos llevaron a hungría a
convertirse en el primer país de la
unión en comprar un fármaco distinto
tras aprobar la vacuna rusa